Porsche eine zeitlose Marke bekannt
dafür legendäre Sportwagen zu bauen die
die Herzen eines jeden Auto Enthusiasten
höher schlagen lassen selber einen
Porsche zu besitzen ist aber gar nicht
mal so einfach das liegt nicht nur an
extrem Nachfrage sondern auch an den
Preisen was wäre also wenn wir es
schaffen würden den Traum vom Porsche
für jedermann greifbar zu machen und
damit noch richtig Kohle zu verdienen
herzlich Willkommen zu folge 8 von
Porsche Trader ab bevor wir aber jetzt
mit dem Video starten sind einige
Retouren wieder bei tameck in den Shop
gekommen also viele Sachen in allen
Größen wieder verfügbar Check den ersten
Link in der Videobeschreibung oder die
Produkte direkt unter dem Video für
neues Shirt neuen Sweater Symphony oder
eine neue Hose vielen Dank für euren
Support und viel Spaß mit dem Video
bisher haben wir rund 2500 € verdient
was eine Menge Kohle ist aber ungefähr
erst ein Viertel von dem Geld dass wir
wirklich brauchen für einen Porsche 944
die heutige Idee hat es aber so sehr in
sich dass ich glaube dass die Potenzial
hat uns wirklich nah ans Ziel von knapp
10.000 € zu bringen bei einem weiteren
und eigentlich viel größeren Ziel könnt
ihr mich aber supporten klick den
kostenlosen Abo Button direkt unter
diesem Video wenn es noch nicht getan
habt und keins der folgenden Videos zu
verpassen und mich dabei zu supporten
dieses Jahr noch die erste Million zu
knacken kommen wir aber zu Ideen genau
so ein Ding geht es zu erarbeiten auf
tiktok habe ich ein Video gesehen wo
jemand Porsche Modelle baut vielleicht
sagt dem ein oder anderen Daniel Arsch
was ist ein Künstler der baut concrete
Models zu so ziemlich allen Gegenständen
die sehen ziemlich cool aus und die sind
ziemlich teuer und tiktok ist dieser
jemand im hergegangen und hat selber
konkrete Models also Beton Modelle von
Autos gebaut vor allem von 91 und ich
habe mich gefragt ob wir das nicht im
großen Stil machen kann in etwas größer
ziemlich groß sogar ich glaube dass sich
die letzten Jahre das Interesse von so
Streetware auch viel zu interior
geschickt hat sehr viele junge Leute
sind in dieses Streetwear Ding
eingestiegen und es gibt tausende Marken
aber im Interieurbereich sind die Sachen
die sehr beliebt sind grundsätzlich sehr
teuer und da eine Möglichkeit zu bieten
günstiger einen krankes Teil zu kommen
machen wir uns zur Aufgabe
das hier ist die Form von so einem RC
Car also von dem ferngesteuerten Auto
und eigentlich schneidet man die einfach
aus setzt das Ding auf seinen Modell
drauf und fährt dann damit so rumgedreht
ist das aber eine Originalform von dem
neuen 11 RSR so eine Form kostet 50 €,
deswegen gilt ist die im besten Falle
mehrmals zu benutzen den kann man sich
dann schön hier in so ein Regal stellen
genauso wie hier und man muss nicht 3000
€ bezahlen wie bei Daniel arschem
sondern wir verticken die dann für 300
oder 350 und jetzt Fackeln wir nicht
länger rum sondern für diese Form aus
und bauen die ersten Modelle
das hier
sind im Prinzip beide Sachen die wir
brauchen einmal Formen Trends Spray und
Figuren Gießmasse ich mache das jetzt
Freestyle wie immer anstatt eine
vernünftige Form zu bauen habe ich den
Karton genommen indem das Ding kam und
einfach T-Shirts reingelegt und das so
ein bisschen zu supporten
[Musik]
erster Test ah
trennzeug vergessen
dreieinhalb Liter brauchen viel mehr
brauchen viel mehr und jetzt ein tiefer
gelegter Porsche
das kommt also dabei raus wenn man
Freestyle an die Sache rangeht fürs
erste sollte es aber reichen nach einer
Stunde war das erste Modell fest boah
Alter das sieht richtig krank aus wenn
es da nicht ein kleines Problem gibt an
dieser Stelle gucken wir ein Stück zu
weit raus um es wirklich rausheben zu
können genauso wie hinten am Heckflügel
es bleibt uns also nichts anderes übrig
als die 50 Euro teure Form kaputt zu
schneiden nur um an das Modell zu kommen
krank also wirkt für mich als hätten wir
mit dem ersten Versuch das perfekte
Material getrunken also die Form einfach
schnell zusammengetaped und weiter
geht's weiter versuchen mit
aufgeschnittener Form wieder zugeklebt
jetzt würde ich fast sagen dass wir eine
Massenproduktion gehen
[Musik]
wunderbar der Modell 2 rausgeholt
ich finde es komplett krank oder die
erste Version aus macht sich schon
ziemlich gut wunderbar das hier
das Version 2 was willst Du dafür nehmen
das hätte ich dich jetzt als nächstes
gefragt 250 was hast du bezahlt und
Material 22 Euro ohne Form
motiviert von Max preiseinschätzung
kaufe ich sofort einige Form nach und
rase in den nächsten Bastelladen um mehr
von dem magischen Keramikpulver zu
kaufen denn so wie wir die Modelle jetzt
herstellen ist doch eigentlich perfekt
oder im dritten Versuch zerschneide ich
die neue Form direkt zu Beginn und
konstruiere mit Bauschaum eine
passgenaue stützende Außenschicht für
mehr Stabilität ist ziemlich perfekt der
Rest bleibt eigentlich gleich wieder
Masse anmischen wieder massenmixen
wieder Form ausgießen und wieder
komplett die benötigte Masse
unterschätzen egal was habe ich wieder
gemessen wieder nachträglich Masse
anrühren bevor die erste Ladung zu
trocknen beginnt und wieder einige
Stunden warten bis alles durch hier und
jetzt nur noch das Modell aus der Form
lösen abschleifen ins Regal stellen
begutachten und dann feststellen schon
gut aber
nicht
also jetzt nach wirklich langem
rumprobieren sind die Modelle eigentlich
immer noch zu groß man sieht die
Schnittkante wir kriegen also einfach
keinen perfektes Model hin das sind zwei
Punkte die dazu beitragen dass es
einfach nicht richtig teuer verkauft
werden kann wenn jemand wirklich Kohle
dafür Blech da muss das komplett perfekt
sein und die Oberfläche fühlt sich super
an aber diese Schnittkante wegen dieser
scheiß Hülle ist da und bleibt da fühlt
sich so ein bisschen an wie so ein dead
and das Modell ist mit 50 cm unheimlich
groß und dadurch auch mit rund 7
Kilogramm extrem schwer damit verringert
sich nicht nur die Zielgruppe fürs
Produkt weil man eine Menge Platz
braucht um das Modell hinzustellen
sondern der Versand wird auch unheimlich
teuer und ziemlich heikel weil es sehr
leicht kaputt gehen kann des weiteren
ist es einfach nicht klingen genug durch
das Aufschneiden der Form bildet sich
eine hässliche Schnittkante die auch
durch Schleifen nicht verschwindet in
meiner Verzweiflung fange ich an einen
Alternativprodukt zu entwickeln einen
halben Porsche den man sich an die Wand
hängen kann und das ist auch alles schön
und gut und das Endprodukt sieht sogar
gar nicht so schlecht aus aber es löst
immer auch nicht unser Hauptproblem wir
brauchen einfach ein kleineres Modell
die Karosserieformen die wir bisher
genutzt haben gibt es nur in einer Größe
uns bleibt also nichts übrig als all in
zu gehen und uns unsere eigene Form zu
bauen in 3D marketplaces findet man zu
so ziemlich allem ein 3D-Modell und für
den erschwinglichen Preis von 100 Euro
haben wir jetzt ein sehr detailliertes
Modell dass wir mit der Hilfe eines
Kumpels erst vereinfachen um unseren
minimalistischen Look gerecht zu werden
und es dann von genau diesem Kumpel in
3D drucken zu lassen aber nicht nur die
Form an sich sondern auch alles
drumherum soll besser werden um
bestmögliche Qualität zu erreichen
während wir also auf unser kleineres
neues Modell warten testen eine neue
Möglichkeiten für die Form und zwar mit
Silikon
diese Sprühdose wird das neue interior
piece des Jahres und zwar auch aus
dieser Keramik Gießmasse und damit wir
eine Form haben die wir wieder benutzen
können machen wir jetzt eine Negativform
davon mit diesem Silikon den wir besorgt
haben und damit testen wir das ganze
jetzt rein da oben wieder verwendbare
Form alles bestens in der Theorie ist
Silikon top geeignet am allerwichtigsten
die Form ist wiederverwendbar also kein
weiteres aufschneiden von irgendwelchen
teuren Formen sondern einmal eine Form
machen und die tausende Male verwenden
und außerdem ist es quasi unsere letzte
Option funktioniert diese Option mit der
Silikonform nicht ist das Projekt
offiziell gescheitert gut oder der große
große Moment nach 48 Stunden Ding ist
ausgehärtet meine ist das äh jetzt gut
um wirklich die Modelle von der Graffiti
Dose zu machen zum anderen ist das auch
der Test für die Porsche Modelle so
sieht das jetzt hier am Ende aus ist im
Prinzip ein riesen silikonblock der die
perfekte Form für uns bedeutet und was
ich schon mal gut anfühlt ich konnte das
gut aus der Form bekommen was
hoffentlich auch bedeutet dass wir die
Graffiti Dose gut aus der Form bekommen
deswegen müssen das jetzt so
aufschneiden dass wir die Dose raus
bekommen und nachher dass Material diese
Keramik wieder gut rein gegossen
bekommen
krass Alter das funktioniert ja
bombastico
das sieht übrigens krass aus also sofort
neue Masse angerührt und ausprobiert
moment of truth wie sieht's aus
[Musik]
Alter und damit ist es entschieden das
ist die perfekte Methode nach so vielen
Wochen versuchen und Problemen endlich
ein Licht am Ende des Tunnels ist doch
geil das kann dann so ein schönes 29
Euro Produkt im Shop sein weißt du wenn
du nicht die 79 für ein Porsche ausgeben
willst und so auch der 3D Druck mit der
perfekten Form ist jetzt endlich da noch
nicht super clean aber dazu später mehr
über die letzten Tage haben wir dieses
Modell ja anfertigen lassen die anderen
Modelle sind uns einfach zu groß im
Verkauf mein ganz im Ernst wer hat genug
Platz für so ein Modell das hier ist
eine größte die viel besser auf jeden
Schreibtisch passt die in jeden Schrank
passt die irgendwie auch von dem
Proportionen her weiß ich nicht einfach
cooler ist und genau davon machen wir
jetzt wieder so eine Silikonform und
schauen ob das Final wirklich unser
Porsche Produkt sein kann oder nicht
[Musik]
sieht perfekt aus
Alter das sieht sehr perfekt aus um
ehrlich zu sein ich werde das direkt
begießen müssen und die großen Moment
vielleicht unsere finale Form der drei
Wochen hat diese Scheiße 4 Wochen mit
testen hin und her das könnte jetzt der
Moment sein oh mein Gott
[Musik]
und dieses Zeug liebe ich wie am ersten
Tag
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es Reisen
gefühlt drei Stunden von der perfekten
Form entfernt
[Musik]
nach echten wirklich fünf Wochen des
rumprobierens haben wir es tatsächlich
geschafft und ein Produkt erstellt mit
dem ich glaube dass wir wirklich Kohle
verdienen können wenn es das 3D-Modell
nicht ganz Erstellen der zweiten Form
zerfetzt sind Probleme sind aber wie
unser Finanzminister sagt nur dornige
Chancen weswegen wir uns dazu
entschieden haben ein neues 3D
druckmodell zu erstellen und das in
einem besseren Verfahren mit viel
höherem die Masse an Leuten die Porsche
so sehr feiern dass sie sich in den
Abdruck bestellen um ihn zu Hause
irgendwohin zu stellen ist glaube ich
wirklich groß und das war auch mit
Abstand die aufwendigste Porsche Trader
oder Trader an sich Produktsuche und
Produkt Erstellung jemals bisher haben
wir aber Kosten in Höhe von
[Musik]
was wirklich eine Menge ist in der
nächsten Folge kümmern wir uns um
Vermarktung und Verkauf und beantworten
die Frage wie viel Geld wir verdienen
können wenn ihr das nicht verpassen
wollt vergesst nicht den Kanal zu
abonnieren und dieses Video zu liken das
was von mir wir sehen uns im nächsten
Video wieder
[Musik]